لتعليق على اجتماع رانشتاين معنا من
المانيا السيد محمد جاسم الخبير في الامن
الدولي ومدير مركز مكافحه الارهاب
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
همم محمد جاسم هذا الاجتماع الجديد للدول
الداعمه لاوكرانيا في رانشتاين يعيد طرح
الاسئله والتساؤل الكبير بخصوص هذه
المساعدات المقدمه من قبل سواء واشنطن
لندن او باريس الى اوكرانيا والحديثه الان
عن اسلحه ثقيله
ومدرعات هل يمكن ان نعتبر ان الغربي يشارك
في هذه الحرب او يصل الى الحد اعلان الحرب
على روسيا يمكن لا تعتبر ذلك روسيا
نعم وصف الوضع الحالي انقراض الدول
اوروبا الغرب جميعها اجتها انه على حافه
الحرب الشامله وهذا جاء بعد ان تغيرت
استراتيجيات النيته ودول اوروبا والغرب
بتقديم اسلحه متقدمه ومتطوره على غرار
باتريوت على سبيل المثال والان نتحدث عن
دبابات ايضا متطوره
ربما
ابرامز هذه جميع حاله تقول بانها
على وشك ان ينخرط بحرب الشعب الهو وهذا
يبعث في رساله واضحه الى موسكو ولذلك كان
رد فعل موسكو بانها ممكن ان تبدا صفحه او
بالاحرى هي بدات صفحه جديده في هذه الحرب
يعني نستطيع ان نقول حرف اوكرانيا روسيا
لكن
سيد محمد جاسم الى اي ماده يمكن ان نقول
ان هذه الدول في حرب مع روسيا لانها مثلا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حتى المانيا
تقول انها تقدم مساعدات لاوكرانيا لكن لم
تصل الى حد الدخول في مواجهه مع روسيا
لانها لم تقدم اسلحه كبيره يمكن ان تقلب
موازينها الحرب على الارض
هذا هو واضح هذا واضح بين النيته لا توجد
لديه قواته على اوكرانيا وكذلك دول اوروبا
لا توجد لديها قوات على الناتو على
اوكرانيا لكن رغم ذلك اجد انه نوعيه
التسلح ونوعيه هذه الامدادات هي تبعت
برساله الى روسيا بان المواجهه مع موسكو
يعني تغيرت وهنالك لانه نوعيه الاسلحه
التي بدات تقدمها الدول الناميه اصبحت غير
ذلك ف- اا مهما كان عدم وجود قوات ربما من
اننيته على اراضي اوكرانيه لكن هذا لا
يمنع بان النيته الان متورطه بتقديم
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا كون انه هذه الاسلحه
هي متقدمه وممكن ان تهدد العمق الروسي
وهذا هو ما يثير قلق روسيا وتحتبر ان
الحرب الان هي على حافه حرب تكون اوسع من
الحرب التي بدات في فبراير من عام الماضي
السيد محمد جاسم ما هي حدودها الدول
الغربيه ايضا في نوعيه الاسلحه التي تقدم
الى اوكرانيا
وبدون ان تصل الى حد انها دخلت في حرب
مباشر
يعني بشكل رسمي انا لا استطيع انه موجود
انه يعني عدم
نوعيه همم الاسلحه على سبيل المثاله لان
نتحدث عن الدبابات ليبوردو اوبراز
الامريكي اجت انه الغرب ايضا لا يريد ايضا
هنرد في هذه الحرب فلذلك هو يريد ان يقدم
الامدادات الى روسيا الى اوكرانيا في سبيل
ان تستطيع استرجاع اراضيها التي تم
احتلالها من روسيا فاذا فلذلك انلاحظ انه
هي محدوده وجد انه لا له ولايه المتحده
وكذلك ان هي تريد ان تنخرطها في حرب واسعه
وكذلك روسيا ايضا هي لا تريد ذلك فيجد انه
هنالك تصعيد في التسلق ونستطيع ان
اختصارهم بانه هنالك الردع والردع المضاد
وما بينه وروسيا في سبيل الان لا يكون
هنالك ربما تغيير في الموقف الميداني
وربما حتى في الموقف السياسي على مستوى
استراتي
السيد محمد جاسم الخبير في الامن الدولي
ومدير مركز مكافحه الارهاب والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لك